ciao a tutti
bentornato utilizzatore oggi andremo a
vedere dei modi per copiare assurdi
copiare non sono questi mezzi di ma ogni
tanto ci suggeriva mondo i compagni
tornava di matematica matematica
soprattutto per tu io ho diciotto mezzo
e qual era la sua tecnica i bigliettini
altri passaggi non ho i bigliettini
proprio piegati a fisarmonica è come
rimettere a giorno il sistema
infallibile erano minuscoli simboli
scriviamo molto piccoli oppure di
scrivere al computer tuo carattere più
piccolo in assoluto ma non crediamo
tutti e disarmonica bulimia però nella
mano così lo scrivevo attraverso
attraverso ma non riuscivo a leggere
dove mi diranno di aver fallito quando
dovevo cambiare
diciamo un foglietto spiegazzato della
fisarmonica frico un attimino cambiato
e non si sa mai cercato come foglietti
così interessante peccato che quando
punto con la tecnica che lo slargo tra
compagni quindi parlavamo qui dopo uno
le all'inizio della glassa l'altro alla
fine che trovo molto utile mettersi al
primo banco che di solito avevo capito
che di solito quelli là diciamo meno
preparati si mettevano sempre dietro le
c mettiamoci dietro così copiamo però i
professori non sono mica stupidi in
alternativa mancavano dietro quindi io
che furono discutendo gli metteva
davanti perché sapevo che il professore
stava dietro a controllare altri nuovo
garantisco lidar assistono quasi al
primo banco purtroppo ma
assicuravano sia davanti che al centro
che viene è l'anno di occhio tanto
karmico stata creata anche formazioni
che andremo a vedere questi metodi
assurdi che sono stati utilizzati
appunto da degli studenti a lunghi per
copiare super curiose mi dispiace di
newsweek questi metodi come caramazza
però non copiano meglio se venite
beccati alla fine qui mezzo di
divertenti che useremo per l'inter
vedere cosa si sono inventati e mi
raccomando la più bella è che se volete
vedere altri meglio come queste altre
ragazze nori cose assurde scuola lo
shopping online
iniziamo subito dai curioso primo metodo
quello di scrivere con la matita di esse
una calcolatrice perché ma fine si vede
ma non troppo in giro curatrice si può
sempre tenere su bach quindi allora
secondo metodo formentin l'unghia
a parte come ha fatto a scrivere così
così così lasciano puoi fare solo quando
lo facevo io sul funzionamento che hai
mantenuto bertolo solo con uno script
che devi mettere un fogliettino dentro
l'appello cosmati la penna
metti un fogliettino con le risposte è
quella che se lo vuoi passare a qualche
compagno del normale questo detto metodo
è quello di scrivere dentro la bottiglia
cosa avevo fatto io in un video e
funzionava bene quello che il professore
poi non si renda conto che stai sempre
li a picchiare del marxismo sui
funzionari cresca della fisarmonica che
dicevo io che la metterne mai però
questa abbastanza
in pratica tagli la roma metti dentro
con lo scorso attacchi un fogliettino
con le formule però riesce a nascondersi
dal professore
apprendo dai rumorosi allora ha un'altra
donna con il biglietto dentro però
quest'anno testato tagliata a metà
forse questo bombelli è forse bene
ammette che in un'ottica l'ultimo tir
così interessante interessante quindi si
possa prescrivere poco per questi fronti
di bergamo per quelle due indizi ha sì
perché ce l'hai alberto di bologna è
stato più subito allora proviamo sì un
pochino meglio di una stanza come facevi
all'ente né da una ventina ma molto più
piccolo il mio antigas
quindi dice che deve stare nel palmo
della mano
ma senza farlo vedere per cambiare così
con un cestino all'interno della pagina
come ti sei allenato a scrivere mesi
sottile oppure lo scrive voluto chiudere
poi vertici olivo il carattere per farlo
stare perfettamente nella togliendo
tutti i bordi quindi per risparmiare che
spazio possibile telefonare e di mettere
fuori deciso sotto la scarpa ma poi c'è
l'accesso si espone bce che gli abitanti
quella del piede
questo non l'ho capito forse per una
volta funzionale magari ti abbassi una
volta diventati allacciare le scarpe e
lo guardi però sono una volta forse
funzionale e allora un altro quello di
ha in pratica va messo nella bottiglia
d'acqua ha coperto il tappo con dello
scotch è ammesso il bigliettino tra il
capo e la bottiglia d'acqua dal
rassicurante può funzionare tu puoi far
finta di bene però troppo piccolo si
trova poco spazio
spinge in viaggio per fare questa cosa
c'è l'ha messa dentro la penna quando
metodo che vi scrivevo prima l'ha
smontata passato la penna e poi
abboccato avvocato lapenna praticamente
tipo slot machine per girare per mettere
fine gira gira e si vede resto basta un
altro con la gomma qua la propria
scalata tantissimo e monica funzionare
allora questo non c'è un po strano e so
che per che attiverà ma non prima quando
li non è un po strano frammentate
finissimi non si fa quello che ti cade
ma vabbè addirittura alla descrizione
poggio di voglia di libero praticamente
un foglio gigante delle carte nei
collant e ma per andare poi a leggerlo
devi per forza andare in bagno e
svogliati e leggerlo in classe non lo
puoi mandare sicuramente intimisti
questo tema si è un po rischioso però
sto po po strano
eccone un altro sempre a quanto pare
questi mesi
utilizzato da solo se una ragazza non si
viaggiare il primo ragazzo mostra
relativa diventi intanto comunque ma
cosa ha pensato in questo momento no
questo mi sembra molto interessante
invece in pratica ha preso due righelli
è ammesso il bollettino dentro tutte le
volte un pochettino e vedi la cambiamo
la master o cosa ci costava la si usa
può funzionare questo non lo so diteci
voi nei commenti cosa ne pensate che
dici anche se avete usato qualcuno di
questi trucchetti se ha funzionato o se
abbiano un peccato allora come in
pratica se un ragazzo con un cerotto tra
già abbiamo capito tutti possa essere
graziotto questo 08 ecco qua c'è de sa
die bbc formulato un sistema
conosciutissimo comunque in pratica
questo è il pacchetto di nascondere le
cose sotto il cerotto non lo so ma
reputo che ne pento latte di no anche
perché estasiato li adotta attenzione è
posta a casey questo penso che non lo so
mi ricorda qualcosa
che cosa di nascondere ripreso a giocare
con l'attrice e pratica la custodia no
nel calcolatrice scientifica si hanno
praticamente la custodia che si
estraevano per poi chiuderla tipo
carrellino e quindi se il cavallino
rometti zottola il coperchio diciamo
libri attaccare attaccare
gli argomenti la nova dove ti vuoi
portare attraverso la signora che stai
sempre senza il compito di storia di
jamila filiera calcolatrice che veniva
scolare allora qua più o meno lo stesso
metodo però lo vediamo in azione quindi
mette il bigliettino e il cerotto a
format foto quindi forse addio con la
mano aperta
devi stare attento perché aree di essere
veloce ad emetterlo video vediamo questa
non so perché qua c'è un rischio di come
compiere a scuola e trucchetti quindi
non so forse questo il trucchetto
[Musica]
vediamo quanto righe forse lo stesso
metodo che abbiamo visto prima e cioè di
incollare proietti che non eri viene
questo caso perché la trasparente quindi
potrebbe dotarsi di tele interessante
quesito perché si può funzionare forse
vi diamo matita fa scavando una matita
con la caldo
abbiate il foehn i timoni attorno ma
come far ridere sempre scarabocchi
perchè alla fine non si riesce ad
entrare le età appena il trucco ed enzo
marino tv.it l'altro romantica va beh
non so perché lei poi la mano musiva lo
sta coprendo talmente dal coperchio da
neuer colore così mela non desta
sospetto
lavoro poco per farlo entrare fatti
colada povero per il foglietto ci può
stare un altro complicando così poche
cose che ci vuoi scrivere dentro oddio
sul progetto per tirarlo si può stare
hilton hotels il fantastico interessato
e allora vediamo un po cosa si
suggerisce quasi un mix appunto di
trucchetti per la scuola pd vediamo cosa
è questo
questo post è un trucchetto vediamo un
fai da te forse per la copertina che
carini che sta interessando un vostro in
cina si vota il sacco di tempo per farlo
questo ha fatto un premio un block notes
dall'inizio un gruppo è molto carino ci
vuole un po di tempo che ora l'effetto è
molto bello tutti i colori oddio no non
mi dire questo occhi aperti a scuola per
dormire io mi chiedo g
qualche professore si casca si vede di
questi occhi finti si casca terribile a
voi una spugna bagnata d'acqua la con
cieli a questo per il pranzo a scuola
trattenerlo fresco praticamente questo
allora come disegnare la prospettiva
senza un righello
[Musica]
bello bello
allora se non hai dormito abbastanza
prendi un sacchetto di plastica in filo
di cotone 100 all'ora tagliato con un
sino in un bicchier forest per dipingere
un altro non fa cadere la tinta anche
questo per compiere infatti fai un
libretto per tutte le formule per
gonfiare vivo grazie nella felpa oddio
pressante per le fate comunque queste
cose hanno le fatiche potrebbero
beccarvi e sono guai
ci sono ancora
[Musica]
perché è passato un po stella era un po
brutto quello allora soli una cannuccia
[Musica]
[Applauso]
siamo nella posizione la termina con la
pianta e le costerà meno i metodi più
assurdi che sono stati usati per copiare
il nord ovest e non molto pericolosi a
cinque gare nei commenti quali sono i
vostri metodi o se avete utilizzato la
se avete già sperimentato qualcuno di
questi è frizzante degli altri video di
code assurdo successe a scuola e allora
facciamo quattro cartellini di casa se
volete vedere altri trucchetti e storni
le nostre challenge i video divertenti
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao